can never do anything but guess in this
business because he was such a reclusive
man
but once they the Taliban agreed to talk
to the Afghan government about peace
without total victory you had to begin
to wonder where mullah omar was because
he was a dead end err he was the leader
of the jihad he was the commander of the
faithful there is no way he was going to
compromise those positions by by dealing
with the government he was absolutely
confident would be be gutted by the
Taliban after the Americans and the
British left so this report of his
demise on the eve of the next round of
peace talks so they have any
implications at all for that oh I think
it does I think very much so within the
within the within Afghanistan most the
Taliban field commanders have opposed
this these peace talks and now they've
learned they've been lied to by their
supreme commanders for two for two years
I don't think that the delegation
talking to the Ashraf Ghani government
has much credibility left with the
people who actually are carrying guns
in the international sense MOA
Omar being taking off taken off the
board leaves one man who is claims title
to the count to being a caliph the to
being the commander of the faithful and
that's Abu Bakr al-baghdadi the head of
the Islamic state and this al-qaeda's
groups in Yemen in Libya in Syria all
have been troubled with defections and
intentions to defect to the is forces
and they've been held back in place
mostly by their loathe oath of loyalty
to mullah omar that is now broken and
it's not i don't think it is
transferable ma'am and the other point I
would make for al Qaeda is that they're
going to be extraordinarily angry with
mullah omar who certainly knew that that
or with I'm sorry
with Ayman al-zawahiri the chief of al
Qaeda they'll be extremely angry with
him for mislead
them for two years it's it's it's
unbelievable to suspect that as our
Harry didn't know that Muammar was dead
this is all told very bad news for the
West altum Utley as well mother Omar was
almost this mythical figure at the head
of the table Amman without him he say
the ayahs could rise but does it also
spell the demise of a Taliban ultimately
well it you know I think it's going to
be very hard to find a leader for the
Taliban that people will identify with
in the same terms as Mullah Omar MOA
Omar was a veteran of the Afghan war he
was he did not turn over Osama bin Laden
in effect gave up his government in his
country and now the the people who
surrounded him turned out to be you know
very very significant liars in terms of
his presence and and not announcing his
death I think it's very likely that the
Taliban fighters are now up for grabs in
the sense of another organization
winning their allegiance Michael show
it's good to talk to you thanks our
joining us the sky news tonight thank
you kindly them